[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
vous regardez l'échiquier mondial sur rt
france au sommaire aujourd'hui
l'afghanistan vingt ans après le début
de leur intervention sur le sol afghan
les troupes américaines font leurs
valises
ls le gouvernement officiel afghan
presque seul face aux talibans
une décision qui risque de bouleverser
profondément le paysage géopolitique
régionale le désengagement américain
mais fait que commencer mais les
conséquences se font déjà sentir
début juin le retrait des troupes
américaines est à moitié terminée selon
le plan annoncé en avril par joe biden
le 11 septembre 2021 le dernier soldat
américain quittera le sol afghan
pourtant les talibans ne veulent pas
attendre jusqu'en septembre et exige le
retrait immédiat de toutes les forces
étrangères le gouvernement de kaboul lui
dénonce un risque de guerre civile et
les premiers signes d escalade sont déjà
là dès le mois de mai les talibans
reprennent le contrôle de plusieurs
districts contrôlés jusqu'ici par l'état
kaboul mènent une contre offensive sur
plusieurs fronts
mais le succès est mitigé le nude tire
la sonnette d'alarmé
outre les talibans d'autres groupes
radicaux renforcent leurs activités en
afghanistan dont al-qaïda où l'état
islamique
à l'international les inquiétudes
persistent autour d'une possible
escalade de violence en afghanistan sur
ce fond un certain nombre d'acteurs
régionaux s'activent diplomatiquement la
russie la chine le pakistan et l'inde
ont chacun leur mot à dire dans le
processus de paix afghan
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre en voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur le rapport de forces
dans ce pays déchiré par des années de
guerre c'est le blitz au moment du début
du retrait américain le gouvernement
afghan contrôle complètement la capitale
du pays kaboul et nombre de districts
dans les différentes parties du pays
soit au total environ 30% du territoire
afghan
la sécurité de ces zones est assurée par
les forces de l'ordre afghanes forte
d'environ 300 mille hommes face à eux
les talibans groupe radical reconnue
comme terroriste par l'onu ils étaient
au pouvoir en afghanistan de 96 jusqu'à
l'intervention américaine en 2001 qui
l'a renversé fort de plus de 60 mille
âmes et il contrôle aujourd'hui un
cinquième du territoire afghan
alors que la moitié du pays est disputé
par les deux parties du conflit depuis
2001 l'afghanistan abrite un compte en
jambes militaires deux membres de l'otan
et de partenaires de l'alliance au début
des années 2010
cent trente mille soldats ont été
déployés sur le sol afghan
un maximum historique dans les années
qui suivent leur nombre commence à
diminuer début 2010 21 presque 9000 600
soldats de 36 pays sont déployés dans le
pays
le contingent américain et est
représenté par 2500 soldats
la proportion la plus importante des
forces étrangères stationnées en
afghanistan
un nouveau chapitre s'ouvre dans
l'histoire de l'afghanistan en avril
2021 le président américain joe biden
confirme le retrait des troupes
américaines
la nouvelle date butoir est le 11
septembre 2021 le jour du 20e
anniversaire des attentats de 2001 en
afghanistan cette décision n'a fait que
creuser le fossé entre les deux parties
du conflit
les talibans coupe le dialogue direct
avec les autorités de kaboul et augmente
drastiquement le nombre d' attaque un
certain nombre de pays de la région
créer une escalade après le retrait
définitif des troupes afin d'éviter un
tel scénario la russie la chine le
pakistan et l'inde s'engage de plus en
plus dans le processus de paix afghan
de son côté washington ne voit pas de
menace à la paix dans son retrait et
songe de plus en plus ce regroupement
de ses forces dans la région les
négociations sont même lancés avec
l'ouzbékistan et le tadjikistan
mais pour l'instant sans résultat alors
comment le désengagement américain
peut-il changer le paysage géopolitique
régionale quels sont les risques qui se
dessine devant le gouvernement de kaboul
avec le désengagement américain
comment la nouvelle administration
américaine explique-t-elle sa décision
de retirer les troupes pour répondre à
ces questions nous rejoignons david
rigoulet roze chercheurs à l'ifas
chercheur associé à l'iris et rédacteur
en chef de la revue orient stratégique
monsieur rigoler rose bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord pourquoi selon vous les
etats-unis ont-ils décidé de se retirer
de l'afghanistan maintenant en tout cas
c'est dans le prolongement de ce qui
avait été annoncé sous la pression de
l'administration avec donald trump
de ce point de vue là ya une certaine
continuité qui peut paraître paradoxal
compte tenu des différences politiques
étaient affichés les le nouveau
président joe biden a annoncé le 14
avril
qui est qui décidez de mettre fin qu'il
était temps de finir une guerre sans fin
justement c'est à dire une la plus
longue guerre qui ait jamais eu à mener
des états unis à l'extérieur et donc
effectivement ça clôt ainsi que d'une
vingtaine d'années en arguant du fait
que les objectifs avaient été remplies
que ça justifiait effectivement le
retrait à l'échéance fixée au 11
septembre 2001 donc soit effectivement
vingt ans après avec une accélération
des opérations de retrait puisque
aujourd'hui on estime que 50 % de ces
opérations ont été des jeux d'ores et
déjà effectués est ce que les états unis
ont vraiment atteint leurs objectifs en
afghanistan et ce départ signifie t'il
pour eux un succès ou plutôt un échec à
c'est toujours le problème du verre à
moitié vide et à moitié plein évidemment
ce qui est annoncé par l'administration
c'est que les objectifs initiaux ont été
remplies à savoir qu'il s'agissait de
détruire le sanctuaire d'al qaïda qui
avaient planifié les attentats du
11-septembre et excité finalement
confirmé concrétisée par l'élimination
d'oussama ben laden en mer en mai 2011
donc il y a de ce point de vue là on va
dire qu'il ya un succès minimaliste
même s'il ya un échec relatif par
ailleurs parce qu'effectivement les
ambitions plus plus plus importants qui
avaient pu être formulées dans le
prolongement du renversement du régime
taliban en 2001 ont été revus très très
largement à la baisse et dans quel état
les états unis les styles l'afghanistan
aujourd'hui très brièvement bien il ya
un bilan contrasté parce que évidemment
ça envoie les chèques supposé de
l'opération 2001 il ya eu des progrès
qui sont qui conte doit pas minimiser et
notamment et c'est ce qui inquiète
d'ailleurs une partie des de la jeunesse
afghane aujourd'hui avec un mec c'est là
une alphabétisation notamment globale et
notamment des femmes à hauteur de 35 %
ce qui n'existait pas évidemment sous
les talibans une diversification de
l'accès aux médias
et puis donc un niveau d'éducation
notamment dans les villes et ils
phénomène d'ailleurs de l'urbanisation
avancé de l'afghanistan par rapport à la
période pré pré 2001 donc tous sont tous
ces changements sont importants mais
évidemment en creux se dessine la menace
de reprise du pouvoir par les talibans
et un retour en arrière donc un retour à
l'âge de pierre d'ailleurs évoqué le le
le le chef de l'armée américaine marc
mulet nous évoquerons cette menace dans
la deuxième partie de l'émission
merci beaucoup monsieur rigoler rose
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous retrouvons
à la fin de cette émission pour plus de
détails sur ce thème
merci encore le retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan avance à
grands pas entre avril et juin 300
avions cargos chargés de matériel
d'école du sol afghan et six bases
militaires sont remises au gouvernement
selon l'armée américaine
la mission est accomplie à moitié
nous sommes à mi chemin nous marchons un
rythme confortable pour nous tout se
passe très bien
ce retrait devrait s'achever le 11
septembre vingt ans après les attentats
qui ont servi de prétexte à
l'intervention américaine cette date
butoir est fixée par le nouveau
président américain joe biden le 13
avril dans une allocution télévisée
il annonce sa décision explique ses
raisons principales pour by donne les
états unis ont accompli leur mission à
savoir exclure toute possibilité que ce
pays soit utilisée comme terrain de
préparation d' attaques contre les états
unis 1 outre une concentration des
troupes américaines en afghanistan
empêche selon la présidence américaine
la lutte antiterroriste mondiale il y
est enfin la question du coût selon les
différentes estimations washington
aurait dépensé plus de 2000 milliards de
dollars depuis 2001 la décision de byden
est aussitôt soutenu par les alliés
américains de l'otan qui ont des
milliers de soldats déployés dans le
pays les alliés ont décidé d'entamer le
retrait des forces de la mission résolu
de support d'ici au 1er mai ce retrait
se fera de manière méthodique
coordonnées et réfléchi nous prévoyons
que le retrait de toutes les forces des
états unis de la mission réseau le
supporte sera achevé en quelques mois en
afghanistan pourtant cette décision
semble n'arrange et aucune des deux
parties du conflit
les talibans y voit une violation
flagrante de l'accord conclu en février
2020 avec l'administration trump il
prévoyait entre autres le retrait des
troupes américaines avant mai 2021 côté
américain et la reprise des négociations
directes avec les autorités de kaboul
côté talent et ben ce dialogue et à
d'ailleurs bien démarré en septembre
dernier pour la première fois depuis le
début du conflit
or après la déclaration de baden et les
nouveaux délais annoncés les talibans
rompent avec leurs engagements en
mettant fin au dialogue direct
jusqu'à ce que toutes les forces
étrangères se retirent complètement de
notre patrie l'émirat islamique
les talibans ne participera à aucune
conférence qui prendra des décisions sur
l'afghanistan
l'autre partie du conflit le
gouvernement officiel afghan ne cache
pas non plus son irritation à l'égard du
retrait américain celui ci pourrait
avoir des conséquences désastreuses pour
le pays selon le président afghan
ashraf ghani la probabilité d'une guerre
civile est là et dès le mois de mai les
talibans se lance dans une nouvelle
offensive contre les positions du
gouvernement afghan en quelques semaines
seulement plusieurs districts passe sous
le contrôle des insurgés islamistes
le nombre d' attaque ben allel record en
mai dernier selon le conseiller de
sécurité nationale arguant 1455 attaques
sont perpétrées par les talibans en
faisant des centaines de victimes
civiles le gouvernement lui répond par
des opérations ciblées dans plusieurs
régions du pays mais leurs effets
restent limités c'est l'une des plus
graves crises sécuritaires qu'a connue
le pays ces derniers temps elle se
complexifie davantage avec l'activité
croissante des groupes terroristes
le pays continue d'héberger bon nombre
de groupes armés dont des combattants
terroristes étrangers qui seraient
alliés à divers degrés aux talibans
al-qaïda et à l'état islamique en irak
et au levant et si le gouvernement
arrivé jusqu'ici à défendre tant bien
que mal ses positions à l'aide des
troupes étrangères comment va-t-il faire
après leur départ ce qui complexifie
surtout la tâche d'ashraf ghani c'est la
véritable catastrophe humanitaire et
économique qui est en train de se
produire dans le pays depuis le début
2020 plus de cent mille personnes ont
fui leurs maisons en raison des
violences incessantes selon l'onu
pendant la période de la pandémie le
nombre d'afghans nécessitant une aide
humanitaire a doublé alors que deux
millions de personnes ont perdu leur
travail
le taux de pauvreté lui atteint des
niveaux exorbitants 90% de la population
vit avec moins de deux dollars par jour
parallèlement la production de drogue
est toujours florissante la superficie
consacrée à la culture du pavot à opium
a augmenté de 37 % en 2020 selon
le fils des nations unies contre les
drogues et le crime
alors comment la communauté
internationale réagit tel retrait des
troupes des états unis et de le temps
combien de fois le pentagone at-il
envisagé de se désengager d'afghanistan
et pourquoi aucune de ces tentatives n'a
abouti jusqu'ici
enfin comment le retrait américain
peut-il changer l'échiquier régional
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
le retrait des troupes américaines entre
dans sa phase finale mais va-t-il
aboutir cette fois la plus longues
guerres jamais menée par les états unis
se terminera-t-elle car depuis le début
du conflit plusieurs tentatives de
washington de se désengager
d'afghanistan se sont conclues par un
échec pour des raisons tout à fait
diverses
à la suite des attentats du 11 septembre
2001 les etats-unis et leurs alliés
procède à une intervention militaire en
afghanistan sous prétexte de lutte
antiterroriste principale force
politique du pays depuis 1996 les
talibans sont renversés mais continue la
lutte armée
se considérant comme le seul
gouvernement légitime de l'afghanistan
les états unis et par la suite toute la
communauté internationale reconnaisse la
légitimité du gouvernement afghan par
intérim créé avec la participation de
washington
les effectifs américains passent de
quelques milliers au début de
l'opération jusqu'à une trentaine de
milliers en 2008
pourtant la situation reste fortement
instable attentats fusillade des
dizaines de soldats américains en sont
victimes chaque année alors que les
dépenses pour l'opération se chiffre en
centaines de milliards de dollars dans
ce contexte barack obama fraîchement élu
en 2008 évoque pour la première fois le
retrait des troupes américaines qui
devraient selon lui débuter en 2011
mais afin d'assurer que la transition
complète du pouvoir puissent se dérouler
en paix et en sécurité
obama envoie des troupes supplémentaires
en afghanistan au début des années 2010
leur nombre va jusqu'à une centaine de
milliers un maximum absolu depuis le
début de l'opération en 2010 les projets
de retrait se concrétise
joe biden alors vice président américain
promet un retrait complet vers 2014
l'élimination en 2011 d'oussama ben
laden considéré par washington comme le
principal responsable des attentats du
11 septembre 2001 donne une nouvelle
impulsion aux idées de retrait des
troupes
en été 2011
les premiers soldats américains sont
renvoyés chez eux le retrait semble
commencer le gouvernement afghan reprend
le contrôle de cette zone représentant
21% de la population afghane dans les
années qui suivent
des dizaines de milliers de militaires
américains rentrent chez eux
pourtant en mai 2014 obama décide de
maintenir un contingent américain
jusqu'en 2016 pour des missions
d'entraînement et de lutte
antiterroriste et cela malgré une
farouche opposition du dirigeant afghan
de l'époque
hamid karzaï le retrait des troupes se
ralentit la présence américaine
s'établit à près de dix mille soldats
al'approche de la nouvelle date butoir
nouveau revirement en octobre 2015
obama déclare que la situation en
afghanistan reste très fragile et sous
ce prétexte annonce que près de dix
mille soldats américains resteront dans
le pays durant l'année 2016 et puis le
contingent sera réduit à cinq mille cinq
cents soldats en juillet 2007 il se
trouve que l'effectif de 5500 soldats ne
sera pas suffisant la maison blanche
table désormais sur huit mille quatre
cents à la fin du mandat d'obama fin
l'élection de donald trump aux états
unis et prometteuse de changement dans
la stratégie américaine en afghanistan
ardent partisan de la fin de la guerre
dans ce pays il défend l'idée du retrait
américain depuis 2011
pourtant une fois installé dans le siège
présidentiel
trump ordonne l'envoi de soldats
supplémentaires dans le pays sur fond de
nouvelle détérioration de la situation
étant que l'apaisement n'est pas là
le président américain tente l' approche
diplomatique en 2018
les états unis entament des négociations
directes avec les talibans
washington met sur la table son retrait
contre la coupure définitive par les
talibans des liens avec al-qaïda et
l'engagement des talibans d'entrer dans
des négociations directes avec le
gouvernement afghan
fin février 2020 l'accord est finalement
conclue entre le gouvernement américain
et les talibans en vertu du document
le dernier soldat américain doit quitter
le sol afghan le 1er mai 2021 alors que
les talibans conformément à leurs
engagements
entre-temps contact direct avec le
gouvernement officiel afghan les troupes
américaines par de plus en plus de
l'afghanistan en janvier 2021
il reste deux mille cinq cents soldats
dans le pays pourtant le retrait
ultérieur est freinée par l'arrivée au
pouvoir de joe biden qui annonce en
avril 2021 une nouvelle date butoir en
violation de l'accord conclu entre
l'administration trump et les talibans
pendant que la date du retrait complet
des troupes américaines s'approche
l'instabilité en afghanistan gagne du
terrain et inquiète l'union européenne
le processus de paix est dans l'impasse
et la violence continue nous voyons un
nombre épouvantable de victimes civiles
et je crains que cette violence puissent
encore croître dans un avenir proche
pour minimiser les conséquences
bruxelles annonce déjà que le e
continuera de soutenir le gouvernement
afghan et les efforts de réconciliation
est aussi le souhaiteraient ralentir le
départ américain
c'est ce que rapporte le wall street
journal selon lui washington voulait
avancer son départ au 4 juillet même si
le délai officiel et le 11 septembre
pourtant les alliés européens auraient
demandé de remettre la date butoir au 18
juillet au moins les puissances
occidentales craignent aussi pour la
sécurité de leurs diplomates sur le
terrain une fois le départ des troupes
américaines achevée et pense à fermer
leurs ambassades rapporte le journal
pour parer à ces inquiétudes et
maintenir le contrôle sur la situation
en afghanistan les états unis souhaitent
maintenir une présence dans le voisinage
toujours selon le wall street journal le
pentagone étudie la possibilité de
regrouper les soldats les drones et
d'autres équipements de réponse rapide
dans des pays proches de l'afghanistan
d'après le média les endroits idéaux
seraient les voisins de l'afghanistan
à savoir le tadjikistan et l'ouzbékistan
pour rappel l'ouzbékistan à abriter une
base américaine de 2001 à 2005 puis les
relations se sont détériorées
le tadjikistan lui reçoit de l'aide
militaire américaine depuis 2001 dans le
cas où ces pays d'asie centrale ne
serait pas disponible
washington envisage d'utiliser comme
base
les pays du moyen-orient ou même de
déployer des porte-avions dans l'océan
indien pour intervenir rapidement si
besoin
en effet ces derniers temps les états
unis intensifient les contacts avec
l'ouzbékistan et le tadjikistan
début mai le diplomate américain zalmay
khalilzad visite les deux pays avec un
rôle et à kaboul alors que douchanbé
tachkent pense-t-il des projets
américains de base sur leur territoire
l'ouzbékistan lui a déjà répondu
les documents fondamentaux concernant la
défense contiennent des réponses nettes
et claires à ces questions à savoir
l'impossibilité de la présence de bases
et des objets militaires étrangers sur
notre territoire
de fait après le départ des troupes
américaines en 2005 l'ouzbékistan
interdit toute présence étrangère sur
son sol
quant au tadjikistan il n'a pas le
pouvoir d'autoriser un tel déploiement
tout seul il doit d'abord être approuvé
par l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective organisation régionale qui
comprend entre autres moscou d'ailleurs
la russie est clairement opposé aux
velléités américaines
nous comprenons et possédons même des
informations sur de telles tentatives
qui sont entreprises et qui seront
entreprises
nous nous attendons vraiment à ce que
nos partenaires et nos alliés de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective ne l'acceptent pas préoccupé
par un éventuel débordement de violence
en afghanistan la russie s'engage elle
même auprès des pays de l'asie centrale
fin avril 2021 le ministre russe de la
défense sergueï choïgou seront en visite
officielle au tadjikistan et en
ouzbékistan et signe avec ce dernier un
programme de coopération militaire
stratégique pour quatre ans
début juin les forces spéciales russes
et ouzbeks même des exercices
anti-terroristes conjoint dans les
montagnes avec le tadjikistan
les liens sont encore plus étroits ce
pays abrite déjà une large base
militaire russe et le kremlin se dit
être prêt à faire encore plus pour aider
douchanbé à protéger ses frontières
ainsi moscou financera un nouveau poste
frontière au sud du pays aidera à
moderniser ses armements
et à lutter contre le terrorisme et le
trafic de drogue c'est ce qu'annonce le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov en visite dans le pays
fin mai la russie est engagée depuis
longtemps dans le processus de règlement
afghans elle a accueilli plusieurs
conférences internationales sur le sujet
y compris avec les talibans et le
gouvernement local en tant qu'invité et
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas la seule à
s'activer sur ce front surtout ces
derniers mois pékin déploie aussi des
efforts pour s'imposer auprès de kaboul
dans cette démarche la chine compte sur
le soutien de son allié le pakistan les
chefs de la diplomatie des trois pays
tiennent une conférence début juin une
occasion pour pékin et islamabad de
promettre à kaboul leur soutien en
termes de sécurité et de stabilité
politique
tout d'abord il faut éviter un nouveau
renforcement des forces terroristes qui
peuvent profiter du moment opportun la
chine continuera à jouer un rôle
constructif pour le règlement pacifique
en afghanistan
pourquoi donc cet intérêt de pékin et
bien tout d'abord c'est la question de
la sécurité qui préoccupe la chine plus
particulièrement les liens entre les
cellules afghanes et les combattants
séparatistes ouïgours
il ya aussi l'économie car la chine
cherche de plus en plus à approfondir la
coopération commerciale avec
l'afghanistan en août 2020 pékin signe
un contrat pour 2,2 milliards de dollars
avec kaboul pour aider à exporter ses
pignons de pin et en septembre le
financial times rapporte que la chine a
proposé de gros investissements dans les
projets énergétiques à l'afghanistan et
aurait fait une offre de construction
d'un réseau de routes aux taliban et ses
efforts économiques de pékin sont aussi
liées au pakistan car la chine investit
fortement dans ce pays pour créer un
corridor économique avec l'océan indien
intégré l'afghanistan dans ce réseau
serait un atout majeur pour la puissance
économique chinoise
ce qui déplaît fortement à l'inde
principal adversaire régional de pékin
est d'islamabad
pour contrebalancer leurs futurs
influence en afghanistan l'inde fait son
entrée dans le processus de règlement
politique
longtemps absent de toute négociation
qui inclut les talibans lieu d
il semble réaliser un volte face sur
fond de retrait américain
ainsi l'inde doit participer à la
prochaine conférence sur l'afghanistan à
istanbul en plus les médias afghans
rapporte que new delhi ouvre des chaînes
de communication avec les leaders des
talibans pour l'instant il s'agit des
changes à distance mais et des
rencontres serait aussi en discussion
pour y voir plus clair nous rejoignons
de nouveau david rigoulet roze chercheur
à l'ifan chercheur associé à l'iris et
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique
monsieur rigoler rose selon vous y at il
une menace que les talibans reprennent
le pouvoir en afghanistan à l'éolien
incontestablement une pression qui se
fait de plus en plus forte au fur et à
mesure du retrait des troupes
occidentales et notamment américaines on
a vu que la vie de koundouz était menacé
justement ces derniers jours il ya une
pression autour des villes pourraient
asphyxier les villes les d'aliments en
prit d'ailleurs le contrôle d'un poste
frontière avec le tadjikistan ce qui ne
manque pas d'inquiéter les pays
limitrophes d'ailleurs et donc à une
pression avérée des aliments qui qui
profitent de ce2 solide qui va être
laissées par justement le retrait
occidental
pour pour faire pression sur le
gouvernement et à terme impose
effectivement le retour d'un régime
taliban à kaboul
il ya une chose que je ne comprends pas
c'est que comment ça se fait que en
vente en vingt ans les états unis alors
évidemment il ya eu des progrès
politiques qui ont été réalisés en
afghanistan mais comment ça se fait que
en vingt ans ils n'ont pas réussi à
éradiquer ce mouvement puisque c'est à
c'était ça le but de cette mission de
cette présence tous ces années c'était
ont progressé le régime taliban en 2001
parce qu'il avait offert un sanctuaire à
al-qaïda donc l'objectif c'était pas
entente est à l'origine talent immense
était plutôt c'était plutôt de détruire
le noyau dur d'al qaïda ce qui avait été
fait d'ailleurs dans les opérations à la
fin d'année 2001 et puis avec en
éliminant son chef en 2011
donc l'idée n'était pas d'éradiquer
en tant que tel mental est bon parce
qu'il fait partie de toutes façons de
l'équation socio politique de
l'afghanistan c'est tout le problème
il y avait gagné probablement une
illusion de croire que l'on pourrait
faire disparaître sur le mouvement qui
est dans ancré dans la culture pachtoune
et qui est un élément géopolitique
effectivement déterminant cet échiquier
en revanche la question est posée de
savoir si si ce mouvement a des
prétentions effectivement monopolistique
et hélas excellent jeu par rapport à
l'actuel gouvernement qui d'ailleurs
donc dont le président et son son
vice-président de sont attendus à
vendredi donc demain à washington les
états unis et veulent placer leur base
dans les pays voisins de la gagne et ce
tant pour suivre la situation sur le
terrain pensez vous que c'est réaliste
est suffisant ouais on parle de base en
ouzbékistan et au tadjikistan puisque le
chef du centcom commandement central
américain qui couvre la zone de l'asie
centrale
canettes mckenzie a expliqué que si
l'afghanistan retomber dans le chaos ce
qui semble possible au vu des derniers
événements et que les 16 états unis
avaient besoin d'y retourner il faudrait
qu'il soit capable d'identifier la cible
de troubles de la trouver et d'être
capable de l'éliminer donc c'était très
clair comme comme argumentaire et dans
ce cas là effectivement la possibilité
d'avoir des bases dans les pays
limitrophes d'ailleurs serait bienvenu
pour les pays en question puisqu'on l'a
vu avec les derniers évènements que le
tadjikistan était très inquiet justement
par rapport à la pression des taliban
donc ça c'est ce qu'on va dire garder
des yeux et des oreilles et à proximité
à proximité du pays sans parler de la
présence de la cia qui sera maintenue
puisque le 14 avril dernier le
william burns que chef de la cia a dit
qu'effectivement il avait prévu de
laisser sur place des éléments et des
capacités qui seraient créés justement
pour maintenir une certaine visibilité
sur ce qui se passe à l'intérieur du
pays sur qu'est d'autres les etats-unis
peuvent-ils compter aujourd'hui pour
garder un oeil sur le pays qui a encore
peu aidé kaboul à se maintenir à flot
c'est tout le problème de savoir puisque
une étude qui vient de paraître
justement qui a été relayée par le
washington post dit que après le départ
vraisemblablement contrairement à ce
qu'on pensait au début le régime ne
pourrait pas tenir plus de six mois et
donc on retrouve le syndrome de la chute
du régime pro communistes 1 en 2010 2014
avec najib lula qui avait résisté malgré
tout plusieurs années et qui s'était
effondré au moment de la disparition de
l'union soviétique donc la question elle
met le soutien à la fois économique et
éventuellement militaire des etats unis
mais il ya des engagements qui est acté
donc c'est ce qu'avait laissé entendre
d'ailleurs le secrétaire d'état en tony
blinken en disant que quand il y en a un
retrait et lloris et un effondrement
effectivement du gouvernement merci
beaucoup
david rigaud les roses pour cet
éclairage je rappelle vous êtes
chercheur et les fans chercheur associé
à l'iris et rédacteur en chef de la
revue orient stratégique merci encore
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]